what every person wants and especially
people in the workplace is to be seen
respected valued and protected
that's what we all want and we all have
the opportunity to bring that forward
this is one of the coolest
book packaging
things that i've seen it is about
leadership each and every leader in your
company or in your circle has an
opportunity to lead in a way that
unleashes talent in every single person
in your charge
and there she is
hi evan how are you i'm great tara j
frank in the house
i got your book uh i got this this
morning so i haven't had the time to go
through it and everything but i got this
awesome package it's called the
waymakers and i thought it'd be cool as
a start to kind of go through
the whole idea behind this because this
is one of the coolest
book packaging uh things that i've seen
so quickly
what is this so this is this is our box
why is it shaped like a door what what
is this
well i'm sure we'll get
but a waymaker is someone who opens
doors for other people
so that's why there are doors on the
front of the box
and then as you open it up this is this
was so cool like i had got to show it so
the first thing that i saw actually
before even getting that you had this
amazing letter
so she wrote this awesome letter and
what was cool about it is it's old
school
sealed and the logo i don't know if you
guys can see that well like the logo is
it says the waymakers here uh actually
sealed she's like wow that's so cool
that's a nice little personal touch we
got there so then i open this up and the
first thing i see is is this so it's
like the manifesto of what the waymakers
is so what is the manifesto why is it
wrapped up you know in the cellophane
what's the point of happiness in the box
first of all i love your questions so i
actually wrote the manifesto as soon as
i finished writing the waymakers because
i wanted to have um a clear and poetic
honestly uh articulation of what it
means to make a way for other people and
so i wanted to write that for myself but
i realized when i was done that it's
also
i could share with other people and we
put it we wrapped it like that because
it's frameable quite honestly if
anyone's really inspired by it and feels
like they want to be a waymaker
it's something they can put in front of
them and and have visible to them on an
everyday basis you're talking about
building a movement and you're you're
kind of giving people some of the tools
to be able to build a movement and
remember
what they're doing so it's not just
about
read a book and then it sits on the
shelf but you know it's like hey maybe
you want to maybe you want to post this
up and not everybody will do it but it's
it's a nice like that you the forward
thinking of it um anyway i love people
who are building movement so this this
already as soon as they opened i was
like yes i love this thank you okay so
the next thing was this little box which
i thought was a chocolate everything um
everybody thought it was chocolate i was
like ooh what says goodie she's bribing
me with some chocolates he'd be like
caramel on the inside or something but
but it's better it's a it's a key
and so it fits well with the door theme
of of the box and the whole messaging so
so you know the key says making a way
for everyone what what's the key what's
it all about why a key
well the key is to open the doors right
so if we are the waymaker if we are the
individual who is willing to make a way
for others who have been shut out um
then we use those keys and that could be
insight that could be accessed that
could be opportunity we use those keys
to open doors for other people
so that's the symbolism there right and
a lot of doors are locked or at least
people think that those are locked and
so it's like hey let's let's open the
door and hold it for other people to
walk through
i love it such a good reminder okay
then came these things when i read the
book yet then came came these things and
i have not opened these i thought we
could you know i'd look at it you can
explain what these are uh live while
we're on on camera but it looks like
there's a bunch of cards in here and
some envelopes so what's what's the
point of these
well part of the waymaking journey evan
is building relationships with people
and especially building relationships
across differences so that we can use
what we get to know about people their
dreams their skills their talents and
help create opportunity for them so the
greeting cards are one way that we can
build relationships with other people
there are six in there there's a thank
you and encouragement a congrats um and
this is how we kind of deepen that
connection you know i worked at hallmark
for 21 years so because i worked at
hallmark for so long i started my career
as a greeting card writer it felt
appropriate that we bring that
background and that expertise into this
journey forward
cool i love it well i'm going to dive in
and send some of these out um yeah and
then the last last but not least hey
here's the book there it is waymakers
you guys can check it out uh youtube
i'll link it up in the description below
if you want to go see it and
um
when i first heard about the book and
what you're trying to do uh initially i
thought well how am i going to make
sense of this because a lot of what i do
is entrepreneurship it's not
giant corporations and
for most most entrepreneurs are they're
solo people right so they're not really
even thinking
equity or inclusion because like i'm i'm
one person just trying to get by but it
made me think of
not just team but also um
what we create and this might be a
stretch or this might be like another
branch of the movement but
for my channel this really hit home um
we profile a lot of different successful
and famous entrepreneurs and uh
do you know nichelle nichols
i know the name
okay so she was lieutenant uhura on star
trek yes yes okay the original star trek
right and gene roddenberry who's the
executive producer put her as third in
command of the starship
so it was captain kirk and then spock
and then uhura
and at the time there was there were no
black women
on tv in any kind of position of power
and when i was making my youtube content
i kept getting asked not not like super
often but hey why don't you have more
women on the show or why don't you have
more people of color on the show and if
we're doing a profile on billionaires
the honest answer is it's hard because
there aren't as many women billionaires
and if you want
women billionaires of color
you got oprah
and then
now rihanna hit the list but it's like
it's really really really hard to just
find anybody and so
uh
i never made it a priority until i heard
the story about lieutenant uhura
so
she was on star trek she was gonna quit
the show after year one to go back to
broadway which was her love
and
martin luther king went to go visit her
and said you can't quit the show
because of what you're doing for our
cause and she said but i would rather be
out in the streets marching with you and
he said you're doing it you're you're
doing your march on tv by being on star
trek and so she stayed on the show until
the the whole thing ended and my
favorite part of the story wasn't that i
mean i guess it's gotten like hey
encouraging others martin luther king
showing up encouraging others to like
keep going but
uh whoopi goldberg
remembered seeing uh uhura on tv
run into her mom and and saying mommy
mommy there's a black woman on tv and
she ain't no maid
which then inspired her to become an
actress and so when you see people who
are like you doing something that it
opens the door to say hey maybe i can do
that too
and in in seeing that for whatever
reason that's the story that kind of
clicked for me to say wow we need to do
i need to do a better job as an
entrepreneur in the content i'm sharing
to be able to share more messages i mean
it's a long-winded you know kind of give
him the background but while i was so
excited to have you on the show
is
a lot of what you're preaching is
through kind of the corporate lens but
how can we as entrepreneurs
maybe take what you're doing and apply
it to the products we're making or the
servers they're putting out of the
customers that we're trying to serve
such a good question
and i love that you asked it and i also
love the story because that idea of
representation is such a powerful one
when we see ourselves represented in
other spaces whether it's products or in
levels of leadership inside a company or
marketing and communications we feel
seen right we feel visible
we feel that people are recognizing us
we feel noticed and those are things
that honestly every single person at
work and in life
really needs so it matters to us that we
first of all understand that what every
person wants and especially people in
the workplace is to be seen respected
valued and protected
that's what we all want and we all have
the opportunity to bring that forward
and to make sure we're representing
various points of view uh not only faces
right in places but also ideas
and you know expertise and contribution
and those are the ways that we feel seen
and believe that we can also make our
own way in the world
how do you help people make the
breakthrough that
representation is important because
people will give a lot of lip service to
it but then it doesn't it's not in their
actions and it's not it's not a kpi and
like they're not they're not doing
anything against it so how like the
horror story was the thing that made me
make the breakthrough
how
or the storytelling or is it like
techniques in the book or like how are
you actually getting people to
come on board the movement
yeah the the book is honestly really a
guidebook but here's what i tell
business leaders anyway and i think that
there's something to learn from this for
all of us
when people feel seen represented that
actually helps us with talent attraction
which can also mean consumer acquisition
right if you're if you're an
entrepreneur and you're selling products
etc if people see themselves represented
in the work that you do or in leadership
then they believe they belong in
partnership with you they believe you
value me you care about me and so it
helps with attraction it helps with
acquisition when people feel respected
for their ideas and their expertise and
their experience that really makes them
feel like they belong that they are part
of the team they will give you more of
their effort their energy their passion
you know their their big ideas when
people feel valued they're more likely
to stay with you think about this
through a product lens right because i
grew up in product development when peop
when consumers feel valued by you
they you can retain them they will stay
with you over time and continue to do
business with you and when they feel
protected you know buffered um
shielded right defended all those things
that we know are important to us as
human beings they believe they can trust
you they believe they can trust you and
build a relationship with you that can
last and get stronger over time and so
through a human lens these four needs
are really important that we can deliver
them for people in the workplace but
also just in the marketplace honestly
it feels kind of cold to to put it down
to well we need to hire
at least 25 percent
from x or in my world it's like we need
to have at least
x number of women or people of color in
every it feels like it's cold and
calculated and then you kind of lose the
heart and tension behind it
how
i mean
i mean what gets measured gets improved
what do you guy people do to measure
this to start getting results and not
feel
like it's just a strategy in cold yeah
that they're just checking boxes i mean
at the end
we know that american demography the
world you know population is changing
and evolving really effectively
and if we want to be relevant into the
future genuinely relevant then we need
all of those world views and
perspectives and needs and hopes
represented inside our company the only
way we meet other people's needs
genuinely is if we understand them
intuitively
so that representation serves us on a
lot of different levels but it also
creates a much more vibrant supportive
connected culture inside our companies
and inside our communities one of the
ways i help people figure out what their
representation goals should look like
from an equity standpoint is i say well
who are your consumers for instance so
there are consumer product companies who
are getting 100 percent of their growth
for instance from black women
it makes sense that you should have
black women in your leadership making
decisions if those are really the people
who are growing your business long term
so that's one way we sometimes think
about it other times it's you know who
are your consumers or it's what is the
the demographic makeup of the
communities that you're serving you know
so it's more about just
do you have those ideas and those
perspectives inside your company so that
you can meet the needs of those outside
your company
who can help you grow
and so
do you give a card or a checklist or
like help in in
quantifying it so that they can
they can get to the end of the year or
end of the month or quarter and say hey
like we're making progress on this yeah
i help people think about it but you
know honestly i help them frame it and
think about how they might set goals but
the real the thing about the waymakers
that is so powerful to me and to the
people that i work with
is it is about leadership so it's not
really about about just numbers right or
about just targets it's saying each and
every leader in your company or in your
circle has an opportunity to lead in a
way that unleashes talent in every
single person in your charge so not just
the black and brown people not just the
women but if you can behave in a way and
make choices in a way that makes every
single person feel seen respected valued
protected then you will have a more
successful team and a more successful
company so yes there's the numbers part
of this but there's also the human part
of this there's also the relationship
piece of this and we all have an
opportunity as leaders to lead forward
in a much more human connected and
compassionate way and that's really what
the book is about it's it's people say
is it a diversity book and i say not
really
it's a leadership book with inclusion at
the heart of it
so i mean i live in canada and we might
be a little more inclusive or at least
growing up like we're all from different
cultures and backgrounds
i remember i did a series on my youtube
channel where we did a week showcasing
women so it's just women like the whole
week was women which is actually pretty
well received i mean it didn't it didn't
blow up in terms of numbers but the
comments were great and then we did a
series on black excellence profiling
black entrepreneurs and their stories
and the amount of negativity
it was it was like very love or hate
right
the people who felt seen loved it and
and everybody else not everybody else
but there was a very vocal minority
um and that was shocking to me what
level of disrespect there was
um people ask me like well where's the
white excellent series uh and i say hey
i feel pretty well represented by the
content on my channel
uh and so i had like of all the series
that i've ever put up on my channel that
was the one i had to be the most on top
of the comments for the negativity
is there is there something about race
versus gender gender or other things
that
that um because i was blown like i
didn't expect it that was that was a big
blind spot for me and i you know maybe i
was in tune with american culture but is
um
is there is there that big a divide are
you seeing that too or is my experience
just different well i'm so glad you
brought this up honestly because it is
very real i think when we ignore the
fact that there is a percentage of the
american population or any population
who really is comfortable with and
prefers
to preserve that power and position that
has been enjoyed for so many centuries
and they don't necessarily want to see
it evolve they don't want there to be
equitable outcomes they don't want
diversity to be represented they truly
want things to stay the way they are and
even possibly go back to the way they
were
right a few decades ago when there was
even more of a gap
between what everyone has access to and
opportunity for so what i tell companies
honestly because they're starting to
feel this backlash for sure whatever
happens in society happens at work too
because we are people um and we go
between those two places i tell them
look anytime you take on any major
change you're always going to have 20
percent of the people on the front end
like let's change let's do it let's
progress and 20 on the back end saying
let's preserve you know crossing their
arms digging their heels and basically
basically saying don't touch my stuff
but 60 of the people are going to be in
the middle they're going to be sitting
on the fence watching observing trying
to figure out if they have a role to
play and if so what that role is and
quite honestly evan is an invitation to
those people it's not trying to convince
the 20 on the back end that they should
want equity i know they don't they know
they don't that's okay that's normal and
it's also not saying to the 20 percent
you're not doing enough it's saying to
the 60 without you we cannot make
progress without you don't get to equity
we don't get to representation and we
don't get to move forward collectively
what about things that that may not be
as visible
you know so i mean you can you can
tell the difference you know gender
and you know color your skin etc but how
about how about things that may not be
as visible that people are uh you know
afraid to admit or come out or say
things about themselves
is that
i mean assume that's part of the message
and what you're trying to do how do we
how do we account for
things when it's not is it still back to
just who are your customers and let's
bring them in like how do we how do we
recruit or or find the people who are
it's not as visible a choice
yeah i think when you communicate to
people the kind of company organization
entity you want to be right when you
really clearly articulate your intent
what are your values what are your
beliefs what is your preferred future
and you communicate that in a way that
everybody knows they have a place with
you that they belong with you they will
be respected and considered and valued i
think what you're doing is opening the
door for lots of different kinds of
people you're not necessarily saying we
only want these people or those people
you're saying all people are welcome
here with your unique perspectives and
experiences and your differentiated
ideas that's why my work honestly is
really human-centric you know it's
it's not about how do you get more brown
people in your company it's saying how
do you create the kind of climate with
your leadership every day
that ensures everyone feels seen
everyone feels respected and if we can
lean forward in that way with
recognition for the fact that not
everyone has felt seen has felt
respected or valued then we can make
more conscious choices right and
mitigate our biases uh a lot more
intentionally so you know this is mental
health awareness month i have suffered
from generalized anxiety my entire life
as long as i can remember i had my first
uh i i think episode when i was about
seven you know six or seven that i can
remember that is an invisible right
disability that i don't necessarily lead
with but that changes sometimes the way
that i show up and if i have the kind of
relationship with a leader where i trust
them where i feel they have my best
interests and heart where they care
about what i'm aspiring to then i may
feel safe enough at some point to be
honest about the ways that i feel
limited and it gives them an opportunity
to support me and then us an opportunity
to grow together so this human-centric
leadership is really what i'm peeing
into and what i want leaders to learn to
do better which is why i wrote the book
yeah i love that and it's kind of
opening up some new
pathways or questions for me because i
think a lot of entrepreneurs you know
again may not have a thousand people on
their team but even hiring the first
person or second person
if somebody
either has something that's visibly you
know different than the leader or or
invisibly i mean honestly everybody's
got something yeah um
how do we create
the
curiosity or
um
the the state space you know for
somebody to
to be able to share with us as leaders
social entrepreneurs are maybe not the
best leaders at the beginning because
the first time that they're hiring
people how do we create that environment
so that people are kind of sharing their
experience which might very be very
different than ours
yeah i'll share a really pointed tool
with with you all because
really helpful there are two things one
we can establish a psychological
contract up front with each individual
or small team which sounds like this hey
evan welcome to my team i'm so glad
you're here i want to share with you
what this company is really about what i
aspire to this is the kind of leader i
hope to be i also want to invite you if
i ever show up in a way that is counter
to what i just described i want to
invite you to let me know you know to
give me that feedback i'm learning i'm
growing we have to do this together and
i don't get any better as a leader
without your engagement and your
feedback and your support so if you
publish a psychological contract like
that up front then you provide an anchor
for people in your team to respond to
when they need
right and so if someone would arrive
they can say well remember that
conversation we had in the very
beginning
and they can walk through that door
another tool that i actually talk about
in the book is what i call the
commitment cycle and what that looks
like is bringing people together whether
it's two people or a thousand people
well not a thousand or two people or
fifty people to say if we had the most
ideal environment or team climate like
the best climate you could possibly
imagine what would that feel like right
what would be happening in that climate
what would it look like and people just
basically blurred out adjectives and
phrases that describe to them the ideal
climate then you ask people well how
would we have to behave in order to
achieve that let's talk about behaviors
then you ask people what does each of us
need to behave that way and lastly
what is each of us willing to commit
what this does is it makes sure that
everyone gets heard
and it also allows you to create a
collaborative idea vision right of the
kind of team climate you want to create
and it keeps people accountable for
doing so
well people love that they're saying
i've never heard that from a leader
before
so that but leaders got to read this
book so that we hear that a lot more in
the culture um who are your heroes like
who who do you look up to who's doing
this
uh or at least inspires you to be a
better leader yourself
yeah so i have two huge heroes honestly
um who inspire me every day and have
ever since i was young
oprah winfrey for me is someone who has
created uh you know connections and
meaningful impact with people just by
being curious
by being curious and caring about what
other people are experiencing and making
a way for them so she's a huge waymaker
for me although she doesn't know it
and then um i work yeah she doesn't know
it yet right she doesn't know it yet
check i'll i receive that
and talking angelo i actually worked
directly with her as her editorial
partner for about a decade i was at
hallmark and
you know i had so many teachable moments
when i worked with her during that
period of time it started when 25 and
went until i was 35
and i will never forget just the times
when she kind of leaned in and told me
you know you're worthy of being here you
deserve that seat you're as worthy of it
as anyone don't give it up for anyone
and really encouraged me to claim my
space uh to raise my voice to step into
right um my future and and to be
confident in my abilities what was crazy
is i was the greeting card expert but
she was obviously you know an amazing
writer and renowned poet and she would
send me legal pads worth of greeting
card writing because we did a product
line with her and i would have to kind
of look at it and think about what
adjustments we might want to make in
order for it to fit on greeting cards
and call her and we would go through the
writing
and it's crazy when i think about it now
because i was 25 and like she was super
famous beloved
but she was so respectful
of what i knew and understood even as he
had achieved such phenomenal success and
to feel respected by her at that time
and seen by her knowing that our life
experience was so
you know there was such a chasm there um
was a feeling i will never forget right
and so i try to mirror that in my life
today i try to make sure people do feel
seen and respected by me because i do
see them and i do respect them
when you pick two people who are
very patient and willing to listen and
open i remember when jay-z went on oprah
and she didn't like how he kept using
the n-word and he used it all the time i
don't know if you saw that episode um
and he's he's saying it's really
empowering like he uses an empowering we
take your label and we're gonna flip it
and she she just they never got on the
same page on it but
the willingness to come on and even have
the conversation
to not just default close down the other
person's perspective and like the
willingness to listen i may not agree
with you but i'm going to listen and at
least gain more a little more
perspective
um have you seen mary kay ash's story
uh no
it may interest you so she she was the
top uh salesperson at
a company um
and then she was
i don't know like her whole entire story
yeah yeah she eventually just got kept
getting passed over for promotion so she
left to join another company she became
a top salesperson there joins the board
every idea that she puts out is being
rejected by the board says mary you're
just thinking like a woman and like
rejected reject every single idea and it
got to the point where she trained
somebody
um
to then ultimately that person got
promoted to be her boss so her trainee
became her boss got twice her salary so
she quit the company and she wrote a
manifesto kind of like this but it's
more like a mini book she wrote a
manifesto for like how women can win in
the corporate world
and she she made a list of here's what
ideally what an ideal company should
look like
and then she said well instead of just
telling people how to do it why don't i
just build a company
and that's what led to mary kate
cosmetics you know billing plus and
sales everything else and it's just like
the idea of
like opening the door for other people
being the waymaker of i struggled with
this and i want other people not to
struggle as much as i did but but [ __ ]
like it takes courage to become the
waymaker
it it really does and i'm glad you said
that because you know a lot of us have
good intentions but i talk about the
book our good intent is not enough right
we can we can sit there i tell a story
in the beginning of the book of a
conversation i had with a former boss
where i was like i was saying we need to
put some things in place to really try
to get better at this work and and he
said and i love him by the way but he
said i don't think we need to do
anything formal you know the people here
are good people and they want to do the
right thing
and i think that assumes too much i
think it assumes people know what the
right thing is
and it assumes that even if they do know
what the right thing is that they have
the courage to actually do it
and that's not always the case so this
work requires clarity
it requires competence and it absolutely
requires the kind of courage that's
going to push you through the
inconvenience the discomfort the fear
that somebody's going to come and make a
comment that's hateful right
and try to push you backwards but it
takes all of those things i believe we
have the capacity for it though uh and i
believe that we can and i want to help
people do it
for that for just that piece on clarity
what do people
don't know what to do like maybe they're
not the ceo they don't run a giant
company
um but they
love everything you're saying because
like but
what do i do
how do we get more clarity on what our
next step could be to help
yeah so if anybody out there is a
product developer or a service developer
the first thing we do when we're about
to create a new product is what we do
consumer research right
we look to see what the trends are we
try to understand what people need
even what they need that they may not be
able to articulate yet and we do that by
talking to people by talking to
potential consumers and having
conversations and doing research and the
same first step is critical inside our
companies we have to have conversations
with people listening sessions or
experience surveys to get a really clear
sense of what they're experiencing today
and let that insight guide us forward
sometimes people call me and they say
well what's the manual what are the best
practices what are other companies doing
and i say well i can tell you that but
that doesn't mean what they're doing is
what you should be doing
you should be doing the things that are
going to create a better
safer right more a vibrant employee
experience for your people
and you're not going to know what that
is until you know what they're
experiencing today
so that's really the first step and and
that insight can be so instructive for
us when we think about what we're going
to do first how we're going to invest
right and how we're going to bring
people along
i love it and i mean even just listening
just just listen to people and they'll
tell you what's going on in their life
if they don't feel judged yeah even for
colleagues like you may not be managing
them but they're just colleagues
just listening to them could make a huge
difference
this is people i always say that i'm
like hey everybody we make this
sometimes it's not easy but it is simple
this is like good old-fashioned peopling
if we can be better people for each
other we can be better leaders
cool well i love i love the theme i love
the message i love the movement i'm
looking forward to dive into the book
last question you've done so much to
help people you've done so much to to
you know to give to the world i mean my
audience now learning about you if
people were to hold you in their prayers
tonight
what would you have them pray for oh my
god thank you so much for asking me that
i pray that this book gets into
as many leaders hands as possible so
that they can not only read it but use
it
to create more equitable and more
inclusive workplaces i want every single
person at work to feel seen respected
valued and protected and to do their
best and fulfill their aspirations so
more leaders hands
more leaders reading it and using it
that's what i pray for every night
i love it well the book is called the
waymakers youtube we've linked it up in
the description below thank you so much
for coming on sharing your story and the
movement that you you've been creating
for us thank you so much and thank you
for your patience
we made it work we made it work it's
great
all right take care bye see you soon to
see my recent 101 with mel robbins check
the video right there next to me i think
you'll love it continue to believe i'll
see you there i hate you evan i hope you
lose evan i hope your business goes
bankrupt evan evan you're a terrible
person i spent the first
40-some years of my life trying to be
somebody else